in maths we know that a right angle
measures 90 degrees but what are the
other angles and the types let's see
this angle which measures 90 degrees is
called a right angle when we rotate this
arm like this the angle obtained is 180
degrees and it is called a straight
angle or a straight line if we rotate
the same arm completely and bring it
back to the original place which will be
360 degrees it is called a full angle
similarly there are interesting regions
too the angles between 0 and 90 degrees
are called acute angles so suppose we
have 63 degrees or 72 degrees then these
angles are called acute angles
similarly angles between 90 degrees and
180 degrees are obtuse angles
the angles between 180 degrees and 360
degrees are called reflex angles
if you liked the video then please hit
the like button and for more such
interesting math concepts do subscribe
to our youtube channel